I don't know if that's gonna be okay but
it's not good a knee injury has
sidelined country singer Janet Kramer's
partner Gleb troupe dancer Alan Burstyn
is rehearsing with her now I got Alan
doctors are keeping a close eye on
gloves injury but show producers tell et
it's too soon to know if he'll be able
to dance on Monday show 1 2 3 4
meantime IndyCar driver James
Hinchcliffe is also practicing with a
fill-in Pro his partner Sharna Burgess
is still dealing with her knee injury
after slipping in rehearsal before this
week's show James competed Monday with
progenitor onsen but still managed to
earn a perfect school Michele checked in
on the now trio at rehearsal janice
still dancing with James as Charlotte
coaches them from the sidelines
how is the patient I'm doing everything
I can to get back as soon as I can
did your gut tell you anything my gut is
not so sure about Monday but it's pretty
confident about the next one so we have
to make the semi-finals
if China's able to come back what are
you gonna you know what do you what do
you say to these guys this your last
week with them I mean I I'll still be
their number one cheerleader and I'll be
pushing for them the whole way so you
think they can win for sure I'm really
sad to lose Jenn being a part of our
team though like we've got a great
little chemistry going on we have fun
kind of like Three's Company a little
bit I get beat up on a lot that's true
but at the same time I'm kind of the
luckiest guy cuz I've got two pros right